et avec new line dhabi gohelle et gilet
jaune bonjour merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors est-ce que ce
1er mai a une saveur particulière cette
année une saveur particulière avant tout
merci de m'accorder la parade de m'avoir
invité et car effectivement obtenu de
toutes les intimidations que j'ai pu
recevoir ces derniers temps je suis
toujours là et je serai toujours là même
si cette intimidation touche aussi ma
famille proche
je tenais juste à faire cette petite
parenthèse et je vous remercie rt de
données et m'accorder cette parole cette
année deux premiers mais un goût
particulier dans le sens où pour une
fois pour une fois depuis le temps qu'on
essaie de rallier toutes les buts en une
en une masse et en une force c'est en
train enfin de prendre forme
il est temps effectivement que la
population toutes les catégories
économiques et sociales de notre pays
n'importe quel secteur peu importe le
niveau de vie doivent aujourd'hui se
rassembler et ne faire cas c'est ça le
peuple uni si ça doit être au travers
d'une date syndicales ou au travers d'un
d'une structure particulière pourquoi
pas tant que cela laisse la place au
peuple de s'exprimer leur désarroi leur
désaccord fondamental et vis-à-vis de
cette gestion de crise mais aussi la
gestion de notre nation est aujourd'hui
oui je suis contente de voir autant de
monde autant de ralliement des quatre
coins de la france des de toutes les
classes économique et sociale et
professionnelle parce qu'il était temps
il est enfin temps alors les injustices
sociales ans que vous dénoncez depuis le
début du mouvement dg des autres à quel
point c'est un geste y sont elles
étaient exacerbées par la crise
sanitaire actuelle
écoutez à quel point il suffit juste de
sortir dans la rue de tendre votre micro
ainsi que sur tous les médias mainstream
d'aller voir la population chez elle au
bas de chez elle
voir ce qu'ils vivent au quotidien ce
qui a changé dans leur quotidien tout
simplement je ne venais pas moi la
prétention de dire que je sais où j'ai
vu non c'est au peuple de s'exprimer et
ce peuple s'exprime aujourd'hui tous
ensemble dans la rue comme ils
s'expriment tous les jours les
le gouvernement ne l'entend pas et les
médias mainstream ne relate pas cette
information est la parole de ce peuple
est en train de mourir
ça a changé quoi bien sûr que beaucoup
plus de précarité
les prix ont flambé parce que kia a été
regardée l'alimentation vous avez les
factures les taxes sur les factures
compte augmenter la réforme de la
sécurité sociale qui est passée en
janvier énormément foyer travailleurs
smica et moins du smi ont perdu des
aides
ce sont les nouveaux précaires de cette
année qui en rajoute encore plus sur ce
qu'ils ont dit que monsieur bako a
poussé dans la rue et toutes ces
personnes doivent aujourd'hui se réunir
et unis parce que si nous continuons à
laisser faire cette politique sous
couvert de la crise sanitaire
on va en arriver à à perdre même jusqu'à
notre droit d'avoir notre propre opinion
elect frais mais quand je fais référence
à l'allocution de monsieur darmana de
cette semaine plus on y va et plus on a
bien compris que nous tombons dans un
auteur un état totalitaire qui ne s'en
cachent même plus donc à un moment donné
aujourd'hui c'est bien nos libertés
cette liberté de réclamer de demander le
partage des richesses une reconnaissance
sociale
un équilibre social and i'd équilibre de
la paix sociale a bien communautaire
quand vous voyez que tout ces
propagandes sous couvert de ceci cela
c'est une cocotte minute en pleine
ébullition ce qui se passe le peuple
risque d'imploser et c'est là où j'ai
envie d'alerter le peuvent
l'implosion pas nous ne sommes pas des
ennemis au sein même du peuple nous
sommes un peuple qui souffre des causes
de cette gestion gouvernementale c'est
eux l'ennemi du peuple
et aujourd'hui il faut effectivement se
rassembler sous le signe de l'union
l'union du papier toutes les communautés
et 100 communautés toutes les religions
et sans religion toutes les croyances et
sans croyance
on est tous humains où nous souffrons
tous de la même façon et ses souffrances
viennent de l'unique et même cause leur
décision gouvernementale leur mauvaise
gestion de la nation in de bi govou
donc peser dans le débat public que
votre voix soient entendues mais si
cette voie à l'été décisionnaires pensez
vous que vous structurez un
politiquement serait un plus à quelques
mois de l'élection présidentielle
vous voulez que je sois franche et
directe ou hypocrite c'est mieux
d'accord je vais rester égal à moi même
cette structure politique pourquoi pas
s'il ya des gens qui veulent y croire
qu'il y ait une phase en totale
sincérité et en totale un truisme en
laissant la place pour la voix du peuple
adpp le peuple dans son ensemble sans
aucune distinction
mais là encore il ya encore beaucoup de
travail parce que c'est il faut
travailler sur le terrain afin
d'éradiquer toutes les discriminations
sociales communautaires et cetera et
cetera qu'on nous a engendré et
insuffler de la société par toutes ces
mains toute cette structure politique
ambiante depuis quarante ans ça ya du
chemin à faire
maintenant j'ai envie de vous dire quand
tu regarde moi les débats sur les médias
mainstream qui sont déjà en train de
travailler l'opinion publique sur les
présidentielles de 2022 ou il ne laisse
aucune place à un outsider
vous avez vite compris que les dés sont
pipés d'avancé je suis désolé je dis les
choses comme je les vois comme je les
ressens moi je ne pense qu'à une chose
la masse du peuple uni dans la rue fera
plier les choses dans le bon sens on
n'est pas obligé de tout cas ce été volé
on n'est pas la peau sombre et dans le
cas où on veut éviter le chaos
ce n'est certainement pas en leur
donnant ça sur un plateau on écoute tout
à fait capables de s'unir et de dire à
ce gouvernement soit vous nous écoutez
soit vous acceptez de rencontrer
délégation citoyenne du peuple pour le
peuple
et on change la constitution ensemble et
vous laisser la place à la parole du
peuple dans ce système gouvernemental
ou alors vous dégagez c'est aussi simple
que ça il suffit de voir certains pays
ils ont réussi soit arrivé la roumanie
et bien d'autres pays il soit arrivé
sans pour autant monter en guerre
sociale ou guerre civile ou quoi que ce
soit maintenant la structure politique
honnêtement j'ai envie de vous dire ils
nous ont habitués bien à s'accrocher à
leur petit siège doré vous croyez
certainement qu'ils vont eux ils vont là
c'est un house ils vont lâcher leur
siège d'un outsider du peuple pour le
peuple
je ne crois pas sauf si c'est le peuple
tout entier qui va in the big o
merci en tout cas d'avoir répondu à nos
questions j'en rappelle vous êtes membre
dg des jaunes merci à vous